For centuries the Forresters have been loyal
bannermen to House Stark.
A house of traitors.You rely on your on your ironwood, that much is clear.
It would be a shame to see it fall into the the hands of another house
I imagine you would do anything to prevent that from happening.
Wouldn't you?
Hey Youtubers, It's Charlie! So this is going to be a breakdown
of the Telltale Game of Thrones trailer.
We saw a couple of familiar faces.
There will be 5 playable characters in the game.
And it will be released probably before the second week in  December,
My weekly Game of Thrones giveaway will now be for copies of the game,
officially starting now. So all  you have to do to enter that is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
If you don't know anything about the game,
Obviously it looks just like Walking Dead: Wolf Among Us
It's very similar, couple improvements. Instead of the one playable character
like Walking Dead. Like, Clementine.
They have five playable characters. All from House Forrester.
They're the protaganists in the game. You will interact with other main characters.
Obviously, Cersei, Tyrion, Ramsay Snow, or Ramsay Bolton. However you want to think about him.
There will be six episodes that will be posted across the course of next year
and then Season Two obviously around this time.
Pretty much going to work just like The Walking Dead game. It will be digital download on  PS4, Xbox, PC
Pretty much any platform you can think of.
It will cost about the same, too. It will be about 25 bucks for the first game.
And then episodes will be cheaper than that.
In terms of timeline, I know everyone is wondering where this takes place. It's between seasons three and four.
So, it's not going to get into Winds of Winter or season five stuff. You don't have to worry about that.
The big tagline has been: Iron from Ice. And I know she mentioned ironwood in the trailer.
Those are just the trees inside the Wolfswood.
When she said "precious ironwood" it's just wood that's stronger than normal wood.
Even though there are scenes in King's Landing.
Obviously you see Margaery, Cersei, Tyrion, the Iron Throne.
It's primarily it's going to take place up near the Wolfswood.
Your starting location is going to be Ironrath. That's basically, like,  the Forresters version of Winterfell
but, that's the name of their keep.
And as said, bannermen to House Stark.
The first character that we've actually learned about.
The first playable character
is named Asher Forrester. He's one of the exiled sons of Lord Forrester.
His character description reads, "Asher had always been a rebellious youth.
brawling in taverns, sleeping with whores and finding ways to raise his father's ire.
But his life took a dark turn when at age 17.
He fell in love with Gwen Whitehill, The eldest daughter of his Father's bitter rival.
Bloodshed ensued, and Lord Forrester faced a choice.
Go to war, or exile Asher across the Narrow Sea.
He chose the latter.
Asher remains in Essos to this day, living as a sellsword.
Trying not to think about the life he left behind."
So that will also make you guys a little bit excited because that means we get to see the East.
It's possible that he's fighting with The Golden Company.
The Golden Company for those that don't know,
is just a famous group of sellswords that was founded by by bastards from House Targaryen.
a long, long time ago.
I did a bonus video for them already. So I'll link in the description if you want to learn all about 'em.
My big question for you guys though, is that even if season one of this game
doesn't really tie in with the show, a lot. It just deals with characters from the show and side stories.
Would you want to see it tie in with the show or the game at some point?
This is done in conjunction with HBO, like, this is an HBO Telltale Co. production.
I think that was mostly to secure the actor's faces and likeness rights and stuff.
The next big thing we need to see is some gameplay, though.
Presumably, that'll surface in the next couple weeks.
Like I said, going to be doing a whole lot of gameplay of this on my game channel, as well as the main channel.
So, I'm really excited.
There are certain games that come along that you are totally willing to forego sleep for.
And in case you haven't seen my other videos.
Youtube gave me me a new beta feature to play with that's really cool.
If you are watching this on your mobile phone or on a tablet,
there are new links on top of the frame that you can click on.
It'll be the same as the links that I always add over here.
Right now, click here to learn about what George R.R. Martin was saying about the direwolves
in season five, as well as Winds of Winter.
And, click here to learn all about Ancient Valeria.
Thank you so much for watching! So, lets all high five, I'll see you guys tonight.